This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。你有帮助产生真正改变的愿望吗？拉西特学院，为你提供“依赖与敏感”项目。掌握这些技能
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
对于陪伴和支持面临健康和依赖问题的人至关重要。建设一份丰富的职业生涯，服务
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
于全国各地的法语社区。不管法语水平如何，这都是可能的
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
在拉西特学院。今天就访问Collage LaC. .A.，这是国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个看到谋杀案
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
由克里瓦克和德皮波实施的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后没有表现出任何悔意，显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将为此抗争到底。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Bone Valley节目中的The Devil's Quarry。快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一个全新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
走向一个更快乐的生活。Joy 101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋和感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈献的Joy 101，主持人是霍达·科特比。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，自我出生以来，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·奥南德斯，
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Wey and Howls on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
并在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。多年来，主流媒体一直将无家可归者表现为单一群体。《We The Un-Housed》是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，当我还在洛杉矶街头无家可归时，我创建了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两获韦比奖的播客，也是唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《We The Un-Housed》。
Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, as we of course. break down the psychology of our 20s back as well for an episode. I know a lot of you have been waiting for. Thank you for your patience. But I just felt like I felt like we had to wait for episode 420 to do this topic for aesthetic purposes, of course. Today we are talking about the psychology of weed. I know a lot of people have thoughts on cannabis usage. And as a drug,
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要
You know, it's obviously very easy to villainize, but cultures and societies have been using cannabis for thousands of years. It is one of the oldest drugs, oldest plants, in fact, that has, it's essentially co-evolved alongside humanity. And as we are, and as society is taking a much more liberal approach to cannabis, I think the psychology behind it is very unexplored and incredibly fascinating. I think the more liberal approach that we're taking to cannabis usage has been really amazing for so many people. It's been adopted for chronic pain management, for therapeutic practices, its roll back a lot of unfair criminalization, amongst many other things. There are still important considerations we do need to know if we want to take part, especially from an emotional, biological and psychological standpoint. You may have heard this thing that, you know, no one has ever overdosed from weed.
你知道，这显然很容易被妖魔化，但文化和社会的各个角落使用大麻已经有几千年了。它实际上是最古老的药物、最古老的植物之一，它基本上与人类共同进化。随着我们，随着社会对大麻采取更加开明的方法，我认为其背后的心理学是非常未被探索且令人难以置信的着迷。我认为我们对大麻使用采取的更加开明的方法对很多人来说真的很棒。它已被用于慢性疼痛管理、治疗实践，回滚了许多不公平的刑事定罪，以及许多其他事情。如果我们想参与其中，我们仍然需要了解重要的注意事项，特别是在情感、生物和心理学角度。你可能听过这样一句话，你知道，从来没有人因为大麻而过量吸食。
We need to kind of debunk these a little bit. There are two sides to cannabis consumption that mean that it can be as dangerous as it is liberating and enjoyable. So that's what we're going to talk about today, as well as just the science and what it does to your brain, why it makes you more hungry, why certain people get anxious, other people don't. There's going to, of course, be some resources in the description if you need them or if this episode brings up any concerns about dependence. for you or someone you know. We are going to take a very scientific approach today. So, as always, this episode isn't an endorsement of doing drugs.
我们需要稍微揭穿这些说法。大麻消费有两个方面，这意味着它既具有危险性，也具有解放性和娱乐性。所以这就是我们今天要讨论的内容，以及科学和它对你大脑的作用，为什么它让你更饿，为什么有些人会焦虑，而另一些人不会。如果需要的话，或者如果这一期节目引发了关于你或你认识的人的依赖的任何担忧，简介中当然会有一些资源。我们今天要采用非常科学的方法。所以，像往常一样，这一期节目并不是对吸毒的认可。
But let's be honest, I'm in my 20s. I went to a university and a state was, you know, marijuana was legal. So I'm not going to be a hypocrite and say, don't do it or pass any judgment. Or for your usage or lack of usage, I just think the psychology is very fascinating. It's important purely from like a research standpoint. weed is just has this so much cool information about it. So without further ado, let's get into it. To begin understanding the psychology of weed, we have to start with knowing what the heck
但老实说，我正值二十岁。我上过一所大学，所在的州，你知道，大麻是合法的。所以我不会当伪君子说不要这样做，或者对你的使用或不使用做出任何判断。我只是认为心理学非常迷人。单纯从研究的角度来看，大麻有太多很酷的信息。所以废话不多说，让我们开始吧。要开始理解大麻的心理学，我们必须首先了解到底是什么
it actually does to our brains and bodies to make us feel the way it does. Basically, where does the high feeling come from? A lot of the feeling of being high starts with something called the endocanabinole. system. This is a natural system in your body, everybody's body, and in your brain as well, and it helps regulate mood, stress, appetite, memory, pain, reward, even how strongly we react to things around us, basically how we interpret sensations. In other words, it is involved in many of the exact same functions that people notice shifting when they consume weed. Fun fact, the endocannabinoid system is also the same system responsible for the high feeling that some people get from exercise.
它实际上对我们的大脑和身体做了什么，让我们有这种感觉。基本上，兴奋感是从哪里来的？很多兴奋感始于一种叫做内源性大麻素系统的东西。这是你身体里的一种自然系统，每个人身体里都有，你的大脑里也有，它帮助调节情绪、压力、食欲、记忆、疼痛、奖励，甚至我们对周围事物的反应强度，基本上是我们如何解释感觉。换句话说，它参与了人们在吸食大麻时注意到的完全相同的许多功能。有趣的事实是，内源性大麻素系统也是导致某些人因运动而产生兴奋感的同一个系统。
Everybody has an endocannabinoid system and every body naturally produces its own endocanabinoid molecules. Whether you smoke weed, whether you don't, whether you've ever seen weed, looked at weed, smelt weed or not. Your body already has a system in place. In particular, your body naturally produces two well-neutral. known cannabis-like chemicals anandamide, which is known as the Bliss molecule and 2AG. These chemicals naturally bind to cannabinoid receptors in your body to influence mood, pain, appetite, memory. Another fun fact, a Harvard report found that we actually have more cannabinoid receptors in
每个人都有内源性大麻素系统，每个人的身体都会自然产生自己的内源性大麻素分子。无论你是否吸食大麻，无论你是否见过大麻、看过来大麻、闻过大麻与否。你的身体已经有了一个现成的系统。特别是，你的身体会自然产生两种中性的物质。已知的类似大麻的化学物质是花生四烯酸乙醇胺（anandamide），被称为极乐分子，以及2AG。这些化学物质自然地结合到你身体里的受体上，以影响情绪、疼痛、食欲、记忆。另一个有趣的事实是，哈佛的一份报告发现，我们体内实际上有更多的受体，
our bodies, specifically CB1 receptors, than nearly any other receptor in our brain and in our system. That is how important they are to how we function. Now, cannabis works by interfering with this system and acting on those same receptors of which we have many, but in ways that is artificial, meaning basically the chemicals that are coming in weren't naturally produced by the body and may occur at like a higher level than what the body is normally used to, meaning it disrupts the system, meaning we get the symptoms of being high that we are used to. The main reason weed can feel euphoric or strange or calming or even disorientating is because of its chemical makeup. One University of Mississippi study has found that there are over 140 cannabinoids as well as other chemicals that make up the chemical structure of cannabis.
我们的身体，特别是CB1受体，几乎是我们大脑和系统中任何其他受体都无法比拟的。这就是它们对我们功能运作的重要性。现在，大麻通过干扰这个系统并作用于我们拥有的许多相同受体来发挥作用，但方式是人工的，也就是说，进来的化学物质不是身体自然产生的，并且可能以高于身体通常习惯的水平出现，这意味着它扰乱了系统，这意味着我们得到了我们习惯的吸食大麻的症状。大麻能让人感到欣快、奇怪、平静甚至迷失方向的主要原因是因为它的化学成分。密西西比大学的一项研究发现，有超过140种大麻素以及构成大麻化学结构的其他化学物质。
When those enter our body, they kind of flood every single system and they create the reactions that we know. But when we talk about mainly the psychological sensation that accompanies weed, we are mainly talking about two specific cannabinoids that have the most impact, THC and CBD. They are both active components found in cannabis. They affect the body and brain very differently and are the most significant of the chemicals that make up cannabis. So basically they are responsible for the majority of the field. that we have in response to smoking weed or consuming weed. So THC is the main psychoactive component.
当这些物质进入我们的身体时，它们会涌入每一个系统，并产生我们所知的反应。但是当我们主要谈论伴随大麻的心理感觉时，我们主要谈论的是产生最大影响的两种特定大麻素，THC和CBD。它们都是大麻中发现的活性成分。它们对身体和大脑的影响非常不同，是构成大麻的最重要的化学物质。所以基本上它们负责我们吸食或消费大麻的大部分反应。所以THC是主要的精神活性成分。
This is the component most responsible for the classic high that people feel. So that shift in time awareness, the increase in appetite, the foggy memory and thoughts pattern, like thought patterns, everything. And for some people as well, anxiety and paranoia, it's THC. CBD is very different. It does not produce the classic high associated with THC. And it does not seem to bind to the brain's CB1 receptors in the same direct, powerful way that THC does. Instead, CBD has a much broader and more indirect pharmacology. So what that basically means is that THC is coming in and only really hitting one kind of receptor. CBD is hitting multiple different kinds all across the body, including CB2 receptors which actually occur primarily in our immune system. So it's involved in several
这是最能导致人们感受到的经典兴奋感的成分。因此，时间意识的转变、食欲的增加、记忆模糊和思维模式，比如思维模式，一切都是如此。对于某些人来说，焦虑和偏执也是由THC引起的。CBD非常不同。它不会产生与THC相关的经典兴奋感。而且它似乎不像THC那样以相同直接、强大的方式与大脑的CB1受体结合。相反，CBD具有更广泛和间接的药理作用。所以这基本上意味着THC进入并真正只击中了一种受体。CBD正在击中全身多种不同类型的受体，包括主要存在于我们免疫系统中的CB2受体。所以它参与了几个
systems is basically what we're saying. And CBD is what you would often see marketed as medical products. So CBD oil, CBD gummies, CBD drops. Some people think of it as like a weaker weed, but it's a different cannabis compound or derivative entirely with a completely different profile of feelings or sensations. It doesn't create that. same overhaul in our consciousness. In research, it's often described as actually having a potentially calming antipsychotic, anti-convulsant, anti-inflammatory kind of job or role. So whilst THC or typical weed tends to shift our experience psychologically into this altered, intensified state, CBD is better understood as a compound that may influence our body more than our mind,
系统，这基本上就是我们在说的。CBD是你经常看到的作为医疗产品营销的东西。所以CBD油、CBD软糖、CBD滴剂。有些人认为它是一种较弱的大麻，但它是一种完全不同的大麻化合物或衍生物，具有完全不同的感觉或体验特征。它不会产生那种。我们意识中的相同彻底改变。在研究中，它通常被描述为实际上具有潜在的镇静、抗精神病、抗惊厥、抗炎的工作或角色。因此，虽然THC或典型的大麻倾向于在心理上将我们的体验转变为这种改变的、增强的状态，但CBD更好地理解为一种对我们的身体影响大于对我们心灵影响的化合物，
but also our overall ability to regulate. Okay, turning away from medicinal uses, one question I got from a lot of you when I said on Instagram that we were doing this episode is, why does it impact me, why does smoking weed impact me differently compared to my friends, compared to my boyfriend, my girlfriend, I don't know, my parents even. Why do I have such a different response? Two different people could consume the same product, same amount, same everything, and have wildly different psychological experiences, particularly when it comes to feelings of calm versus feelings of anxiety.
但也包括我们的整体调节能力。好吧，抛开药用用途不谈，我在Instagram上说我们要制作这一期节目时，很多人问我的一个问题是，为什么它对我产生影响，为什么吸大麻对我的影响与我的朋友、我的男朋友、我的女朋友、我不知道，甚至我的父母不同。为什么我的反应会有如此大的不同？两个不同的人可以消费相同的产物、相同的数量、相同的一切，却有截然不同的心理体验，特别是在平静的感觉与焦虑的感觉方面。
Now, one of the main reasons is that, and one of the main reasons that has such a different effect is simply because we have different brains and therefore different cannibes. and therefore different cannabinoid systems, different sensitivities to substances, different psychological profiles that impact how we interpret the physical and emotional sensations of weed. This is all affected by things like personality, genetics, stress, even the setting that we are in when we use it. Currently, when we first used it, THC changes how the brain filters attention, filters
现在，主要原因之一是，具有如此不同效果的主要原因之一很简单，因为我们有不同的大脑，因此有不同的内源性物质。因此有不同的内源性大麻素系统，对物质的不同敏感性，影响我们如何解释大麻的身体和情感感觉的不同心理特征。这一切都受到诸如性格、遗传、压力，甚至我们使用它时的环境等因素的影响。目前，当我们第一次使用它时，THC改变了大脑过滤注意力的方式，过滤
reward and emotion, but it can also feel very different depending on what is already going on internally or the state of your CB2 or CB1 receptors. Despite a lot of research suggesting that there is a casual link between cannabis and anxiety, a large 2024 review from research is based at UCLA actually suggests that this association can be best explained by the fact that anxiety predisposing individuals tend to use cannabis more as a method of self-medication. compared to people who don't have an anxiety predisposition. So this suggests that it's not necessarily cannabis usage overall that makes you anxious, makes everybody anxious,
奖励和情感，但根据内部已经在发生的事情或你的CB2或CB1受体的状态，感觉也会非常不同。尽管许多研究表明大麻与焦虑之间存在偶然联系，但加州大学洛杉矶分校研究人员在2024年的一项大型评论实际上表明，这种关联可以通过以下事实得到最好的解释：有焦虑倾向的个人往往更多地将大麻作为自我治疗的方法。与没有焦虑倾向的人相比。这表明，不一定是整体的大麻使用让你感到焦虑，让所有人都感到焦虑，
but it's just that when people with a certain anxiety profile or a certain personality do use cannabis, the effect of that on their anxiety is a lot worse. But also they may be more likely to try it in the first place or lean on it in order to self-sooth because of this promise initially that it's this calming, chill-out, really dopey kind of feeling. Now, how our anxiety presents beyond cannabis use, just in general, is also different from person to person.
但这只是因为当具有特定焦虑特征或特定性格的人使用大麻时，它对他们焦虑的影响要糟糕得多。但他们也可能首先更有可能尝试它，或者因为最初这种平静、放松、真的很呆滞的感觉的承诺而依赖它。现在，除了大麻使用之外，我们的焦虑通常是如何表现的，因人而异。
Some people feel anxious when they feel out of control. Some people feel anxious when they feel like they have too much control and they're too over-stimulated, they're too alert, they're too aware. you can kind of guess which person is going to have a worse reaction. Two people might both think that they're anxious, but for somebody, weed is really calming. For others, it's not. For the person for whom, like, their anxiety really manifests as needing to be alert,
有些人感到失控时会感到焦虑。有些人感到焦虑是因为他们觉得自己有太多的控制权，过于过度刺激，过于警觉，过于清醒。你可以猜到哪个人会有更糟糕的反应。两个人可能都认为自己感到焦虑，但对某个人来说，大麻真的很平静。对其他人来说，则不然。对于那些焦虑真正表现为需要保持警觉的人来说，
wanting to be on top of things, consuming weed might not always give them the break from time, memory, and place and sensations that they want. It just feels like dissociation. and it feels really overwhelming. So maybe I'm not explaining that well, but basically you can come to the table. Like anxiety isn't one type of thing, right? We think of anxiety is this one condition.
想要掌控一切，吸食大麻可能并不总能给他们带来他们想要的摆脱时间、记忆、地点和感觉的休息。这只是一种解离的感觉，感觉非常压倒性。所以也许我没有解释清楚，但基本上你可以走上台面。就像焦虑不是一种单一类型的状况，对吧？我们认为焦虑是这一种状况。
There are actually variants to our anxiety. And that is why even if we're not just comparing anxious and not anxious people, but two, three, four different anxious people, every single one of them could respond differently to weed based on how we interpret and how we relate to body sensations or bodily sensations and how in control we want to feel. Cannabis doesn't just create anxiety out of the blue. It seems to amplify whatever emotion or feeling is already there, such as pre-existing anxiety, especially when the dose of THC is higher. That also may explain why, again, you may have different reactions across two different days because of your
实际上我们的焦虑有变体。这就是为什么即使我们不仅在比较焦虑和不焦虑的人，而是两、三、四个不同的焦虑人群，他们中的每一个人都可以根据我们如何解释和如何与身体感觉或身体感觉相关联以及我们想要感受到多少控制力，对大麻做出不同的反应。大麻并不会无缘无故地产生焦虑。它似乎会放大任何已经存在的情绪或感觉，例如预先存在的焦虑，尤其是当THC剂量较高时。这也可能解释为什么，同样，由于你的
pre-existing emotional state on top of dosage, on top of your environment, on top of what is unconsciously going on for you. One day you're fine. The next day, you're not. This is also the case for things like creativity as well. A lot of people feel way more creative when they're high because our thoughts can feel less filtered and more unusual. It makes whatever emotional state we're in heightened. But the research here is actually really interesting. This was an area I really wanted to look into. And it suggests that feeling creative is not the same as actually being creative. And when people smoke, they just feel creative. They may not actually be more creative, tangibly, practically, physically. One 2023 study found that cannabis use didn't increase actual creativity,
除了剂量、环境、无意识中发生的事情之外，你在两天内的情绪状态不同。有一天你很好。第二天，你就不行了。创造力等事情也是如此。许多人在高潮时会感到更有创造力，因为我们的想法会觉得过滤较少，更加不寻常。它使我们处于的任何情绪状态都得到增强。但这里的研究实际上非常有趣。这是我真的很想研究的一个领域。它表明，感觉有创造力并不等于真正有创造力。当人们吸烟时，他们只是觉得自己有创造力。他们在切实、实际、物理上可能并没有变得更有创造力。2023年的一项研究发现，大麻的使用并没有增加实际的创造力，
but it did make people have biased evaluations of their creativity. Basically, that means they judge their own ideas, other people's ideas, as more creative. So if you've ever been high with your friends and thought, oh my God, this conversation we're having right now is hilarious. This is the funniest thing ever. That was, how has nobody ever thought of that joke or that saying or whatever? We should start a podcast. If you've ever had some bizarre idea for a movie or a joke that you're like, that is just,
但它确实让人们对自己的创造力产生了偏颇的评价。基本上，这意味着他们判断自己的想法、其他人的想法更具有创造力。所以如果你曾经和你的朋友一起嗨过，并想，哦，天哪，我们现在正在进行的谈话太搞笑了。这是有史以来最搞笑的事情。那是，怎么会从来没有人想到那个笑话、那句话或者别的什么？我们应该开始一个播客。如果你曾经对电影或笑话有过一些奇怪的想法，你会觉得，这简直是，
this is genius. And you look back the next morning and you're like, that was really actually unfunny. Like, that really was just bizarre. That's what's happening here. that effect on perceived creativity has struck you. An earlier 2015 research paper also found that highly potent cannabis may actually impair divergent thinking and people that smoke regularly. So, weed may make thoughts feel more novel and exciting in the moment without necessarily
这是天才。第二天早上你回头看时，你会想，那实际上真的很不好笑。就像，那真的只是很奇怪。这就是这里正在发生的事情。对感知创造力的影响击中了你。2015年早些时候的一篇研究论文还发现，高效大麻实际上可能会损害经常吸烟的人的发散思维和智力。所以，大麻可能会让想法在当下感觉更新颖、更令人兴奋，而不一定是
making them better and actually making it harder for us to think differently long term. essentially what we're really talking about is the effect that it has are now in a critic. What we really does is impact emotional control. It can't make you more creative, but it can reduce the pressure and the, I guess, yeah, the pressure and the criticism surrounding you on a daily basis and it just lets your thoughts flow differently. It just weakens your impulses that are perhaps previously holding back creative or non-creative thoughts that you would usually have. What else do we have to mention about how weed impacts us differently? Oh, we have to mention the hunger, the munchies.
使它们变得更好，并实际上使我们在长期内更难进行不同的思考。本质上我们真正谈论的是它对现在的评论家的影响。我们真正做的是影响情绪控制。它不能让你更有创造力，但它可以减轻你日常生活中周围的压力，以及，我想，是的，压力和批评，它只是让你的思维以不同的方式流动。它只是削弱了你以前可能一直在压抑的有创造力或没有创造力的想法的冲动。关于大麻如何对我们产生不同影响，我们还有什么要提的？哦，我们必须提到饥饿，零食。
Because weed makes some people absolutely ravenous. Absolutely ravenous and other people they don't want to touch even their favorite meal. Again, this is because the endocannabinoid system helps regulate not just your appetite, which it does, but also the pleasure and emotional pull of food. THC appears to increase both wanting and liking food. Food can seem more appealing and eating it feels more rewarding based on kind of how THC interacts with your CB1 receptors. That is why the munchies, it's usually not physical hunger. But it's because the sensory experience of eating is so much better. The flavors feel richer, more satisfying.
因为大麻让一些人绝对狼吞虎咽。绝对狼吞虎咽，而另一些人连他们最喜欢的饭菜都不想碰。同样，这是因为内源性大麻素系统不仅有助于调节你的食欲（它确实如此），还有助于调节食物的快乐和情感吸引力。THC似乎增加了对食物的渴望和喜欢。根据THC与你的CB1受体相互作用的方式，食物似乎更有吸引力，吃东西感觉更有回报。这就是为什么零食通常不是物理饥饿。而是因为吃东西的感官体验要好得多。味道感觉更浓郁，更令人满意。
That's why food seems so irresistible. People who feel less reaction to THC though may not have that same drive. And what we're really getting at here is that there are basically dozens of different psychological reaction profiles that you can have from consuming cannabis based on how many CB1 or, or CB2 receptors you have, based on how much weed you're consuming, based on how much weed you've consumed in the past, based on your emotional state, based on your genetics. Again, you could have a completely different experience from somebody sitting across from you and a completely different experience every single time you smoke. The common thread here is that weed doesn't create one fixed effect on people, but that it changes the intensity and meaning of the experience.
这就是为什么食物看起来如此难以抗拒。然而，对THC反应较少的人可能没有同样的驱动力。我们在这里真正要说的是，根据你有多少CB1或CB2受体，根据你消费多少大麻，根据你过去消费了多少大麻，根据你的情绪状态，根据你的遗传，你基本上可以从消费大麻中获得几十种不同的心理反应特征。同样，你可能会有与坐在你对面的人完全不同的体验，并且每次你吸烟时都会有完全不同的体验。这里的共同线索是，大麻不会对人们产生一种固定的效果，而是它改变了体验的强度和意义。
let's talk about the next big cannabis debate. Any guess is what it could be? Okay, it's the question of whether weed is addictive. There is a big myth that I've seen online and heard in person that it's impossible to have a problem with weed because it's not addictive. Is that true or false? Let's break it down. It is true that cannabis is not addictive in exactly the same way as every other drug or alcohol or nicotine, but it's also abysal. absolutely true that it has its own unique pattern of dependency. A useful way to talk about this is to separate biological dependence from psychological dependence. Biological dependence is what happens when
让我们来谈谈下一个关于大麻的重大辩论。猜猜它会是什么？好吧，关于大麻是否会成瘾的问题。我在网上看到并亲自听到过一个巨大的神话，即不可能对大麻有问题，因为它不会成瘾。这是真的还是假的？让我们来剖析一下。大麻不像其他任何毒品、酒精或尼古丁那样完全成瘾，这是真的，但这也是绝对的。绝对真实的是它有自己独特的依赖模式。谈论这一点的一个有用方法是将生物依赖与心理依赖分开。生物依赖是当
the brain and body adapt to regular use of a substance over time. That means that they build up tolerance. It means that they need more of the substance for the same effect. And it also means that if they stop, they may experience physical withdrawal symptoms like irritability, recklessness, sleep problems, low mood, reduced appetite, anxiety. The reason people may say that weed isn't as chemically addictive is because most people don't experience physical withdrawal symptoms the way they do with alcohol or harder drugs that typically affect our dopamine and gabber systems. You know, the next morning you might feel a little bit hazy, but your body, isn't going to physically, isn't going to have the same physical withdrawal pattern.
随着时间的推移，大脑和身体适应了对某种物质的定期使用。这意味着它们建立了耐受性。这意味着它们需要更多的该物质才能达到相同的效果。这也意味着如果它们停下来，它们可能会经历身体戒断症状，如易怒、鲁莽、睡眠问题、情绪低落、食欲减退、焦虑。人们可能说大麻没有那么强化学成瘾性的原因是因为大多数人不会经历像酒精或对我们的多巴胺和伽马系统产生影响的更烈性毒品那样的身体戒断症状。你知道，第二天早上你可能会觉得有点迷糊，但你的身体不会在身体上，不会有相同的身体戒断模式。
Research does show this changes depending on when you start using cannabis. So if you start before 16 or if you smoke a lot, you can develop physical dependency. And your likelihood of having a chemical or a biological addiction is much higher. But psychological dependence is a different story. Weed may not have the same chemical biological pool. but when it becomes a form of emotional and psychological coping, it is just as dangerous. It is just as dependency driven or dependency risky. It can start replacing all other coping.
研究确实表明，这会根据你开始使用大麻的时间而改变。因此，如果你在16岁之前开始或抽很多烟，你就会产生身体依赖。你产生化学或生物成瘾的可能性要高得多。但心理依赖则是另一回事。大麻可能没有相同的化学生物学吸引力。但当它成为一种情感和心理应对方式时，它同样具有危险性。它同样具有依赖驱动性或依赖风险。它开始取代所有其他应对方式。
It becomes difficult to stop, especially when it is the only thing sitting between you and the pain, you and the social anxiety, you and the grief, you and the hopelessness. Its ability to dull or remove intense emotions is, rewarding. It's called negative reinforcement. It removes a bad feeling and that is just as motivational as when something gives us a good feeling and that's why it's so intoxicating. Research into the drive behind cannabis use has consistently found that using weed to coat with distress, with tension, emotional discomfort is linked to more problematic use and worse outcomes. And often because of the way we'd makes us feel, which is maybe quite sluggish, tired,
它变得很难停止，尤其是当它是介于你和痛苦之间、你和社交焦虑之间、你和悲伤之间、你和绝望之间的唯一东西时。它钝化或消除强烈情绪的能力是有回报的。这被称为负强化。它移除了不好的感觉，这和某事给我们好的感觉一样具有动力，这就是为什么它如此令人陶醉。对大麻使用背后驱动力的研究一直发现，使用大麻来应对痛苦、紧张、情感不适与更多有问题的使用和更糟糕的结果有关。通常由于大麻给我们带来的感觉，这可能是相当迟钝、疲倦、
lethargic, we rarely then go on to engage in things that might actually help us. So rather than being something we just use casually for fun, in this situation it becomes emotional management or it becomes escapism from our current situation without actually allowing us to address the root problem. One of the emotions or feelings I feel like links most significantly to cannabis usage is loneliness. This is a great example of how weed can become a way that we avoid the deeper feeling. The literature on the correlation between loneliness and smoking weed is just that, correlational. So we can't say that smoking weed directly causes loneliness because that would be inaccurate. But what a lot of studies, including one in 2016, suggest is that social anxiety,
昏昏欲睡，我们很少会去从事那些实际上可能对我们有帮助的事情。因此，在这种情况下，它不再是我们只是为了好玩而随意使用的东西，而是变成了情绪管理，或者变成了对我们现状的逃避，却没有真正让我们解决根本问题。我觉得与大麻使用联系最显著的情感或感觉之一是孤独。这是大麻如何成为我们逃避更深层次感觉的一种方式的一个很好的例子。关于孤独感与吸大麻之间相关性的文献就是这样的，相关的。所以我们不能说吸大麻直接导致孤独，因为那是不准确的。但许多研究，包括2016年的一项研究表明，社交焦虑，
solitary cannabis use, and cannabis-related problems are often clustered together. And that using cannabis can actually be one of the roots that takes social discomfort and mild isolation and turns it into something more problematic, like full-on solitude and full-on, a bit of a personal loneliness crisis. And this makes a lot of sense. It makes a lot of sense. We can amplify certain emotions that we can feel very self-conscious of in front of people, in front of other people, but it can also make us feel better about other emotions that we feel individually. So therefore, it can become something that we only do by ourselves because we want the, we want the feeling. We don't want to see or be around other people while we have the feeling, but the feeling in itself
孤立使用大麻和与大麻相关的问题通常聚集在一起。使用大麻实际上可以成为将社交不适和轻度孤立转变为更具问题性的事情（如完全的独处和完全的、有点个人孤独危机）的根源之一。这很有道理。这很有道理。我们可以放大我们在人们面前会感到非常自我意识的某些情绪，在其他人面前，但它也可以让我们对我们单独感受到的其他情绪感觉更好。因此，它可能会成为我们只独自做的事情，因为我们想要，我们想要这种感觉。在我们拥有这种感觉时，我们不想看到或与其他人在一起，但这种感觉本身
is still good. And that can mean that the more we really just enjoy that solitary time, smoking alone, consuming alone, the more of a comforting ritual it becomes the more of a habit, the more that it can be a replacement for connection. If someone, maybe it's you right now, starts to use weed, mainly in a solitary manner or to manage a broader sense of loneliness, that is dangerous territory because it becomes harder and harder to come back from. And harder and harder and harder, to, you know, feel okay with being around people. But again, people are different. Like, for some people, it's a purely social activity. It can actually be a really fun source of memories. It just depends on your response and it depends on everybody's response. So I think the thing we
仍然很好。这意味着我们越是真正享受那种独处的时间，独自吸烟，独自消费，它就越成为一种安慰的仪式，越成为一种习惯，它越能成为联系的替代品。如果有人，也许现在就是你，开始使用大麻，主要以独处的方式或为了应对更广泛的孤独感，那是危险的领地，因为它变得越来越难回头。并且越来越难，越来越难，去（你知道）感觉和人们在一起没问题。但同样，人与人不同。就像，对某些人来说，这纯粹是一种社交活动。它实际上可以成为记忆的一个非常有趣的来源。这完全取决于你的反应，并且取决于每个人的反应。所以我想当我们谈论大麻时，我们不能做广泛的笼统陈述，即大麻是坏的。每个大麻使用者都是孤独和抑郁的，因为这根本不是真的。这只是一件需要注意的事情，关于（你知道）独处使用与延长孤独感之间存在着深层的联系，这意味着，是的，孤独感最初可能会导致某人独自吸烟，因为他们没有人可以一起吸烟或消费，但随后它会使情况变得更糟，并且可能成为继续升级该模式的中介因素。好吧，那太激烈了。让我们休息一下。
can't do when we talk about weed is make broad stroke statements that weed is bad. Every weed user is lonely and depressed because it's just not true. It's just something to be aware of about how, you know, there is a deep correlation between solitary usage and extended loneliness, meaning that, yes, loneliness initially might cause somebody to smoke weed by themselves because they don't have anybody to smoke or consume with, but then it can make it worse and it can be a mediating factor that continues to escalate the pattern. Okay, that was so intense. Let's take a break.
我觉得我刚刚对每个人进行了长篇大论。让我们，是的，让我们休息一下。然后让我们谈谈它对我们大脑的影响，它对我们的情绪和动机以及从长远来看对我们人际关系的影响。和我们在一起。经验。你和一位伙伴在蒙特利尔和奥西亚加，在蒙特利尔市中心的Residence Inn住四个晚上。波特航空公司的机票，两张周末黄金门票和1000美元现金。请爱我。Lord、Zara Larson、Dana Gray、Sombor、21 pilots等。下载IHard Radio。收听IHard新音乐。
I feel like I just lectured everybody. Let's, yeah, let's take a break. And then let's talk about the effect that it has on our brain, what it does to our emotions and motivation and also our relationships in the long term. Stay with us. Experience. You and a pal in Montreal and Oceaga with four nights at residents in downtown Montreal. Flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets and $1,000 of cash. Please love me. Lord, Zara Larson, Dana Gray, Sombor, 21 pilots, and more. Download IHard Radio. Listen to IHard new music.
持续10分钟即可参与抽奖。Osiaga，26岁。你收听的每一天都是获胜的另一个机会。当时感觉就像永远不会结束一样。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。
for 10 minutes and entered to win. Osiaga, 26. Every day you listen is another chance to win. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案？是的，长官。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，长官。对一个孩子的强奸和谋杀。这是最糟糕的情况。我想是这样的。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. This is bad as he gets. I would think so.
恶魔，醒醒。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后没有表现出任何悔意，显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我将为此抗争到底。在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听The Devil's Quarry。
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并收听含有独家内容的The Devil's Quarry广告。在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历了乳腺癌，然后帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更加困难。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad, with exclusive content. Subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
有很多人理解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。有大量令人兴奋的内容，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，自我出生以来，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。我还有很多问题。我们从哪里来？
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And there's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Ticharito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
死后会发生什么？你怎么处理取消文化？克里斯蒂亚诺还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常和普通到深刻和非凡
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Christiano or Messi Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像一次深刻的谈话。和你最亲密的朋友。脆弱性显露出来。阴谋论。摆上桌面。目标和经验分享。
This isn't a normal podcast Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine This podcast is like a deep talk With your closest friends Where vulnerability comes out Conspiracy theories End up on the table And goals and lessons are shared
生活中的一切都有完美的秩序。一切都只是。等等我，我要。我将能够连接。查理托。我是哈维尔·利查里诺，与iHeart Radio一起。
All in this life has an order perfect And all is just Wait me, I'm going to be I'm going to be able to connect The Chicharito I'm Javier Licharino and together with IHard Radio
我们将把平凡变得非凡。保持密切关注。这是一个角色。哇。在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts上收听《Learning to Be Human》，
we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a character. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts,
或任何你获取播客的地方。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的残酷描绘，这些故事羞辱、指责并将无家可归者描绘成一个单一群体。《We The In-House》是一个正在改变这一现状的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，
or whatever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of The Un-Housed, stories that shame and blame and paint the Un-Housed as a monolith. We The In-House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson,
创作者和主持人，多年来我一直创造一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQTIA+社区以及制定影响无家可归者生存法律的政策制定者。《We'd Be In-House》是一个两获韦比奖和信号奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周收听我与吉尔·威特勒医生的采访。一位从街头医生转变为网红的人，她对无家可归者社区的工作
creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. We'd be in-hous as a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Whittler. A street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community
在网上和她的社区产生了巨大影响。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Weeley & House。好吧，让我们来谈谈吸大麻对大脑的长期影响，
has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weeley &House on the IHard Radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, let's talk about the long-term effects of smoking weed on
因为我觉得这是很多人都想知道的事情。当人们询问吸大麻的长期影响时。最需要澄清的事情之一是，答案并不是那么简单。一方面，研究并不支持每个吸食大麻的人最终都会受到严重永久性脑损伤的观点。但它也不支持长期吸食大麻完全无害的观点。证据表明，这些影响很大程度上取决于一个人使用的频率、使用的数量以及他们开始时的年龄，
the brain, because I feel like this is something a lot of people want to know about. When people ask about the long-term effects, of smoking weed. One of the most important things to clarify is that the answer is not completely simple. On one hand, research doesn't support the idea that everybody who smokes cannabis will end up with severe permanent brain damage. But it also doesn't support the idea that using weed long term is completely harmless either. What the evidence suggests is that the effects depend a lot on how often somebody uses it, how much they use, and how old they were when they started,
以及他们是否养成了更多的依赖性使用模式。即每周多次持续很长时间。基本上，你开始得越早，使用的频率越高，数量越大，使用的时间越长，与涉及注意力、学习和尤其是工作记忆的问题的相关性就越大。大麻专门影响与学习和记忆密切相关的大脑系统。具体来说，这个被称为海马体的区域，你们可能从过去的剧集中知道，它帮助我们形成和组织新的记忆。
and whether they have developed more dependent patterns of use. So using multiple times a week for extended periods of time. Basically, the younger you start, the more frequently you use, the greater the amount, the longer the period of usage, the greater the correlation with problems involving attention, learning and working memory especially. Cannabis affects brain systems specifically that are heavily involved in learning and memory. Specifically this region called the hippocampus, which you guys probably know from episodes in the past helps us form and organize new memories.
特别是THC与该区域的内源性大麻素受体相互作用，并破坏编码信息的进程，这意味着吸大麻不会抹去我们的记忆，或者消费大麻不会抹去我们的记忆。它的作用意味着信息一开始就没有被正确存储。它只被保存在短期工作记忆中。它从未转化为短期记忆然后长期记忆。这就是为什么吸嗨的人经常会跟不上谈话。他们可能难以保留新信息。他们可能难以在当下解决问题或完成事情，因为工作记忆太短太短。存储时间非常短，存储时间根本不多。所以当受到THC的影响时，很难把所有东西都塞进去。
THC in particular basically interacts with the endocannabinoid receptors in this region and disrupts the process of encoding information, meaning that smoking weed doesn't erase our memories or consuming weed doesn't erase our memories. What it does is mean that the information never gets properly stored in the first place. It just gets held in short-term working memory. It never gets converted into short and then long-term. This is why people who are high often lose track of conversation. They may struggle to hold on to new information. They may struggle to problem solve in the moment or get things done because working memory is so, so short. The storage time is very, there is not much storage time at all. So it's hard to cram everything in there when the influence of THC and
特别是THC，它基本上与这一区域的内源性大麻素受体相互作用，并破坏信息编码的过程，这意味着吸大麻或食用大麻并没有抹去我们的记忆。它所做的是让信息在一开始就无法正确存储。它只被保留在短期工作记忆中，从未转化为短期的再到长期的记忆。这就是为什么处于兴奋状态的人经常会跟不上谈话。他们可能难以记住新信息。他们可能难以在当下解决问题或把事情做好，因为工作记忆实在太短了。存储时间非常短，几乎没有什么存储时间。因此，在THC的影响下，很难把所有东西都塞进脑子里。
of weed in general is disrupting the consolidation of memories needed for short term and long term memory. In the long term, oh my God, I feel like I've said long term, short term memory, all those things a million times. But in the long term, research from 2025 that looks at a sample of over a thousand adults aged 22 to 36 found that heavy lifetime cannabis use is associated with lower brain activation during working memory tasks. And this association remains even in individuals who hadn't necessarily smoked recently or heavily recently. So it suggests that, you know, the impact and effects of weed on cognitive function, even after you quit, even after you taper down, can be long-lasting. Despite reducing slowly over time, you may still feel that your brain is different.
大麻总体上会干扰短期和长期记忆形成所需的记忆巩固过程。从长远来看，天哪，我觉得我已经说过长短期记忆这些词上百万次了。但从长远来看，2025年的一项研究对1000多名22至36岁的成年人样本进行了调查，结果发现，终生大量使用大麻与在工作记忆任务期间较低的大脑激活度有关。而且这种关联即使在那些近期没有或没有大量吸食大麻的人身上依然存在。因此这表明，你知道，大麻对认知功能的影响和作用，甚至在你戒掉之后，在你逐渐减少使用之后，也可能是持久的。尽管随着时间的推移会缓慢减少，你可能仍然会觉得你的大脑变得不一样了。
Our brain does have an amazing and incredible capacity to rewire and restore itself. So it's not to say, like, if the damage is done, you may as well keep going. Like, you're never going to get a certain level of brain functioning back. But it is just, like, important to recognize that if you're sitting here being like, I do notice differences. I don't know if I'm, performing it my best to know that like yeah that's probably correct there is danger to how your brain functions that you should be aware of at the same time there is some evidence to the contrary for when weed specifically medical cannabis is used for medicinal purposes one of the largest ever longitudinal observational studies on the effect of medical cannabis on individuals followed participants
我们的大脑确实具有令人惊叹的、不可思议的重塑和自我修复能力。所以这并不是说，如果损害已经造成，你索性就继续吸下去吧。好像你永远无法恢复某种水平的大脑功能似的。但这只是说，认识到这一点很重要：如果你坐在这里觉得，我确实注意到了差异，我不知道我的表现是不是达到了最佳状态，那么要知道——是的，这可能是对的，你大脑的运作方式确实存在你应该意识到的风险。与此同时，也有一些相反的证据表明，当大麻（特别是医用大麻）用于医疗目的时情况有所不同。历史上针对医用大麻对个人影响的最大规模的纵向观察性研究之一，对参与者进行了追踪
over a two-year period and it assessed them before they started using and then at three months, six months, 12, 15, 18 and 24 months. Even after a few times, even at the three-month mark, patients actually performed better in particular cognitive tasks that required executive functioning. So we're seeing a different pattern. This is a direct quote from the researcher. Her name is Stacey Gruber. She actually runs the marijuana investigations for neuroscientific discovery problem.
为期两年的时间，并在他们开始使用之前以及在第3个月、6个月、12个月、15个月、18个月和24个月时对他们进行了评估。甚至在几次之后，甚至在第3个月的时候，病人在需要执行功能的特定认知任务中的表现实际上更好了。所以我们看到了不同的模式。这是研究人员的一句原话。她的名字叫斯黛西·格鲁伯（Stacey Gruber）。她实际上负责神经科学发现大麻调查项目。
That is a mouthful. And she does heaps of studies around this. But on this study, she said, rather than getting worse, they're actually getting better because their physical symptoms are alleviated. That means they can think more clearly. And often they rely less on other substances like opioids that can disrupt thinking. This contrasts with poorer cognitive performance seen among heavy recreational marijuana users, relative to non-users. There you go.
这个名字可真长。她围绕这个课题做过大量研究。但关于这项研究，她说，患者不仅没有变糟，实际上还在变好，因为他们的身体症状得到了缓解。这意味着他们能更清晰地思考。而且他们通常会减少对其他会干扰思考的物质（如阿片类药物）的依赖。这与大量娱乐性大麻吸食者相比于非吸食者表现出的较差认知表现形成了鲜明对比。就是这样。
So basically what this is saying is that when there's a lesser THC factor, when marijuana is used medicinally, especially for chronic pain or chronic illnesses that are otherwise clouding cognitive capacity, cognitive functioning does go up. So again, you can't, it's not all or nothing. It's not any, any, if you touch cannabis, immediately like 20 times dumber. No, it's a complex interaction with the body, with our emotions, with time, with psychology. Let's turn our attention to motivation. Because of the impact of THC on
所以基本上这意味着，当THC（四氢化酚）成分较少时，当大麻被用于医疗目的时——特别是用于那些原本会模糊认知能力的慢性疼痛或慢性疾病时，认知功能确实会上升。所以再说一次，你不能非黑即白。并不是任何时候，只要你接触大麻，智力就会立马下降20倍。不，这是身体、我们的情绪、时间以及心理之间复杂的相互作用。让我们把注意力转向动机。由于THC对
reward processing and motivation, people often talk about cannabis as if it is automatically something that will turn you into this lazy, zombie-like person. Of course, in the short term, cannabis use does and can reduce motivation, especially in someone who is actively high, like things that require planning and sustained focus, a lot less appealing in that state. Everything that is, you know, the immediate reward is a lot more tantalizing, a lot more naturally attractive during those periods. But long term, the stereotype of like the lazy, unmotivated weed user seems to be incorrect, especially if you're not using every single day or every single way.
奖赏处理和动机的影响，人们经常把大麻说成是会自动把你变成一个懒惰的、行尸走肉般的人的东西。当然，在短期内，大麻的使用确实会而且能够降低动机，特别是在一个人处于亢奋状态时，比如需要计划和持续专注的事情，在这种状态下会显得没那么吸引人。你知道的，所有即时奖励的东西在那些时期都更具诱惑力，更具有天然的吸引力。但从长远来看，诸如懒惰、缺乏动力的大麻吸食者这种刻板印象似乎是不正确的，特别是如果你不是每天都在使用或者不是在方方面面都依赖它的话。
or all the time. Like, you are kind of allowed to have a couple of moments where you aren't heavily motivated because you can sustain motivation elsewhere and in other times of your life. In fact, across newer studies, there is little consistent evidence that all cannabis users are generally less motivated than non-users once you actually look carefully at the data. Some studies, including a significant paper from 23 from researchers at the University of Cambridge and the University of Bath found absolutely no major differences in self-reported motivation, pleasure or willingness to work for reward, especially in non-dependent users. Now, critical point here is self-reported. So obviously, you know, obviously there's like there's a level of trust that we have to believe
或者无时无刻不在使用。比如说，你其实是被允许有那么几个时刻动力不足的，因为你可以在其他地方以及在你人生的其他时期保持动力。事实上，纵观更新的研究，一旦你真正仔细查看数据，就会发现几乎没有一致的证据表明所有大麻使用者的动机普遍低于非使用者。一些研究，包括剑桥大学和巴斯大学的研究人员在2023年发表的一篇重要论文，发现自述动机、快乐或为奖励而工作的意愿并没有任何重大差异，尤其是在没有依赖性的使用者中。现在，这里的一个关键点是“自述”。所以很显然，你知道的，显然我们必须在某种程度上相信
that people know what motivation feels like for them. But a lot of participants, you know, didn't show decline or didn't show differences in their ability to delay pleasure, in their ability to work long-term and steadily and consistently for goals. The other critical thing, though, is non-dependent users. It is a different story when somebody is dependent. This is key. The more convincing concern is always and has always been around heavier use and cannabis use disorder. That is where the issue around motivation,
人们知道对他们而言动力是什么感觉。但是许多参与者（你知道的）并没有表现出延迟满足能力的下降，也没有在为了目标进行长期、稳定和持续工作的能力上表现出差异。然而，另一个关键点是非依赖性使用者。当某人产生依赖时，情况就完全不同了。这是关键所在。更令人信服的担忧一直是、也永远是关于更大量的使用和大麻使用障碍。这才是引发动机问题的地方，
most likely comes up. But the thing is, is that not everybody who uses cannabis is going to go on to become dependent. In fact, it isn't not, it's not unheard of, and it's definitely not rare, but it is not as risky and as common as most people who are opposed to any kind of cannabis usage in society, including for medicinal purposes, would make it seem. One more thing to note here. as well, just like we talked about how long-term cannabis use can impact cognitive, cognitive skills and memory, but that those things can return and can be rebuilt, same goes for motivation. So basically, it's not over. Like, it's not like you have, it's not like you have physically, permanently damaged
最可能出现的情况。但问题是，并不是每个使用大麻的人最终都会产生依赖。事实上，这并不是闻所未闻，也绝对不算罕见，但它并不像社会上大多数反对任何形式大麻使用（包括医疗用途）的人所表现得那样具有风险和普遍。这里还有一件事需要注意。就像我们刚才讨论的长期大麻使用会影响认知技能和记忆，但这些东西可以恢复并且可以重建一样，动机也是如此。所以基本上，一切并没有结束。这并不是说你已经，这并不是说你在生理上永久性地损害了
your entire relationship to reward. like it can be reversed. Let's talk about one final impact that requires close examination, which is the impact of weed on relationships, especially when one person is a frequent user and the other is not. I got a lot of messages about this because it creates a lot of complications, right? There's a lot of pressure to participate. There's different mental stages at different moments or at the same moment. So two people could be in a completely different mindset for connecting and for bonding in the same time period.
你与奖赏的整个关系。这它是可以逆转的。让我们来谈谈需要密切审视的最后一个影响，即大麻对人际关系的影响，尤其是当其中一个人经常使用而另一个人不经常使用时。我收到了很多关于这方面的私信，因为这会产生很多复杂情况，对吧？这里有参与的压力，有在不同时刻或相同时刻不同的精神状态。因此，两个人可能在同一时期处于完全不同的心理状态，从而难以建立连接和培养感情。
There's concerns about somebody's usage when they do feel like they have a problem. There's resentment. There's fear. There's also just plain annoyance that maybe you don't want somebody to be smoking all the time or be high all the time. And they just can't seem to give it up and it's frustrating. There is a lot of potential for weed to shape the way we connect with people. In the short term, cannabis can make us more social and it can feel, and it can make social moments feel easier for some people by lowering tension, by lowering those impulse barriers, by making things seem funnier, by creating shared memories and a shared sense of ease. That is the part of smoking with friends or with partners that can sometimes feel like a bonding opportunity.
人们会担心某个人的使用情况，特别是当他们觉得对方有问题时。这里会有怨恨，会有恐惧，也会有纯粹的烦恼——也许你并不希望某人一直抽大麻或者一直处于亢奋状态。而他们似乎就是戒不掉，这让人感到沮丧。大麻极有可能塑造我们与他人建立连接的方式。在短期内，大麻可以让我们变得更社交，对于某些人来说，通过降低紧张感、降低那些冲动障碍、让事情看起来更有趣、创造共同的记忆和共同的轻松感，它可以让社交时刻感觉更容易。这就是与朋友或伴侣一起吸大麻有时能让人感觉是一种增进感情的机会的部分原因。
Conversations feel a lot looser, laughter comes more easily, ordinary moments are more imaginative, and enjoyable, but in a long-term relationship, sometimes it can feel like, well, why would you need that? Why do you need conversations to be easier? Shouldn't our conversations already be easy? Shouldn't I already make you feel safe and relaxed? Am I not entertaining enough? Like, maybe you need this for other people, but why would you need this for me? Like, I'm your person. And you can very quickly see how insecurity is valid here and can really spark in those moments, especially if you aren't on the same page and there's not full truthfulness. And it is a fair concern from like the loved one, especially if you've had, you know,
对话感觉轻松多了，笑声更容易发出，平常的时刻也更富有想象力和乐趣，但在一段长期的关系中，有时你可能会觉得，好吧，为什么你需要那个？为什么你需要对话变得更容易？难道我们的对话本不应该已经很容易了吗？难道我不应该已经让你感到安全和放松了吗？难道我还不够有趣吗？就像是，也许你在其他人面前需要这个，但为什么你在我面前会需要这个？就像我是你最亲密的人。你可以很快看出，在这种时刻，不安全感在这里是合情合理的，并且真的会被激发出来，特别是如果你们不在同一频上且不够坦诚的话。这是来自爱人的合理担忧，尤其是当你经历过——你知道的——
if they've had partners who've previously ignored them because of weed, previously made them feel insecure, previously rejected them, usage or not, they're coming into this relationship with a different need for openness and a different need to understand your motivations. because being with somebody who smokes a lot of weed even when they're asked not to, or being with somebody who maybe you as a weed smoker or somebody is a weed smoker is with somebody who isn't and they don't understand the relationship you have with it, there's a lot of room for ambiguity. And when we have ambiguity that is not addressed,
如果他们曾经历过伴侣因为大麻而忽视他们、曾让他们感到不安全、曾拒绝过他们的伴侣，无论对方是否使用大麻，他们在进入这段关系时都带着对坦诚的不同需求以及对理解你动机的不同需求。因为和经常吸大麻的人在一起，哪怕是在被要求不要吸的时候；或者和某人在一起，也许你是个大麻吸食者，而对方不是，且对方不理解你与大麻的关系，这其中就有很多模棱两可的空间。而当这种模棱两可没有得到解决时，
we have people come up with their own stories and people come up with their own reasons for why somebody is participating, somebody isn't, that can create a lot of resentment and a lot of fear around the relationship being at risk. It all comes back to this core concern of presence. Relationships of any kind, friendships, family ties, romantic bonds depend on attention, depend on shared memory, responsiveness, and emotional availability. And because cannabis can affect short-term memory as we know, but also motivation and attention, it can sometimes interfere with these key aspects.
我们就会看到人们开始编造各自的故事，并为某人参与或不参与想出各自的理由，这会在关系面临风险时产生大量的怨恨和恐惧。这一切都归结于关于“陪伴”这一核心关切。任何形式的人际关系、友谊、家庭纽带、浪漫关系都依赖于关注、共同的记忆、回应能力和情感上的可得性。正因为大麻会影响短期记忆（正如我们所知），同时也会影响动机和注意力，它有时会干扰这些关键方面。
somebody may seem checked out, forgetful, hard to follow, less reliable, less emotionally engaged. And it's not necessarily because they don't care. It's because weed is changing how they present in that interaction. And if that becomes a pattern, other people, especially loved ones, start to feel a kind of distance. That's actually pretty awkward to bring up. Another issue is that cannabis can sometimes become part of avoidance in relationships more broadly. if someone uses weed after stress, after moments of loneliness, conflict, boredom, emotional discomfort, it may help them feel better quickly, but it can also make them less likely to reach out,
某人可能会显得心不在焉、健忘、让人难以捉摸、不那么可靠、在情感上的投入也更少。这并不一定是因为他们不在乎。而是因为大麻正在改变他们在这种互动中的表现方式。如果这成了一种模式，其他人，尤其是爱人，就会开始感受到一种距离感。这其实是个挺尴尬的话题。另一个问题是，大麻有时会在更广泛的层面上成为人际关系中逃避现实的一种方式。如果有人在经历压力、孤独、冲突、无聊、情感不适之后使用大麻，这可能会让他们感觉好受一些，但这也可能让他们更不愿意去主动联系、
to repair, explain themselves, or sit with difficult emotions alongside other people. And that is the foundation of deep relationships, romantic or not. The risk is not just that someone smokes and becomes distant, but that cannabis becomes their preferred way of managing feelings that would otherwise lead them to connect with somebody that they loved. Again, it all comes down to this psychological dependency and psychological emotional management of discomfort. Listen, we can't not mention the positive side.
去修复、去解释自己，或者与其他人一起默默承受困难的情绪。而这正是深厚人际关系（无论是否是恋爱关系）的基础。风险不仅在于某人吸大麻并变得疏离，而在于大麻成为了他们管理情绪的首选方式，而这些情绪本应促使他们与所爱的人建立连接。再说一次，这一切都归结为这种心理依赖以及对不适感的心理与情感管理。听着，我们不能不提积极的一面。
Cannabis can improve intimacy, especially for people with chronic pain or a lot of stress and anxiety around sex. I've heard that from some people, you know, it's the only thing that allows them to really feel in the moment with somebody. It can also be bonding just because it's funny. You know, two of my best friends smoke weed and play video games together as like a little treat every few months. And honestly, it sounds like a blast and it sounds like something that really nurtures their relationship. And honestly, like when I hear about it, I'm like, God, you guys, that sounds really, really fun. But when should we be worried about it?
大麻可以增进亲密感，尤其是对于患有慢性疼痛或对性生活有大量压力和焦虑的人来说。我从一些人那里听到过，你知道，这是唯一能让他们真正感受到与某人融于当下的东西。它也可以增进感情，仅仅是因为它很有趣。你知道，我的两个最好朋友每隔几个月就会一起抽大麻、玩电子游戏，当成一个小小的犒赏。老实说，听起来这非常带劲，而且听起来像是那种真正能维系他们关系的事情。说实话，每当听到这个，我都会想，天哪，你们听上去真的、真的很有趣。但是，我们什么时候该为此担心呢？
when does it flip over? I'd say you should be worried individually or in terms of your relationship with somebody when weed starts to change your behavior in a very clear, observable way to you. Not observable to everybody else to you. Like you can notice it. That might mean you keep using more than you planned. You find yourself smoking earlier in the day, smoking on days you said you wouldn't, building your routine around when you can get high next.
它在什么时候会发生质变？我想说，当你或你与某人的关系中，大麻开始以一种对你自己而言非常清晰、可观察的方式改变你的行为时，你就该担心了。不是对别人可观察，是对你自己。就像你自己能注意到。这可能意味着你使用的量超过了你的计划。你发现自己一天中更早地开始抽，在你原本说不抽的日子里抽，把你的日常作息围绕着“什么时候能吸大麻”来安排。
One of the clearest signs is loss of control. And that's what all of these come down to. You feel like your life is oriented and centered around this substance. And when you're going to consume it, how much with who, when is the next available time or period where you can do it? And you no longer feel in control of your relationship to it. You kind of know deep down, like, I keep saying I could stop. I keep saying I don't need this, but every time I'm given the opportunity, every time I'm not given the opportunity, I just always find
最明显的迹象之一就是失控。这也是所有这些问题的最终归宿。你觉得你的生活完全围绕着这种物质在运转和定位。什么时候消费它，消费多少，和谁一起，下一次可以消费的时间或周期是什么时候？你不再觉得你能掌控自己与它的关系。你内心深处其实知道，就像，“我一直在说我可以停下来。我一直在说我不需要这个，”但每次给我机会的时候，每次不给我机会的时候，我都总是发现
myself saying yes, I always find myself back here. You should also pay attention to when weed starts affecting you emotionally in a way that is more about reducing negative emotions rather than increasing only positive ones. Basically, if getting high is no longer mainly about the pleasure aspect and about elevating experiences and making experiences better, and it's more about not wanting to feel a certain thing, not wanting to feel stressed, bored, awkward, or overwhelmed, that is a different relationship with the substance.
自己说“好”，我总是发现自己又回到了这里。你还应该注意，当大麻开始在情感上影响你，并且这种影响更多地是为了减少负面情绪而不是仅仅增加积极情绪时。基本上，如果吸嗨不再主要是为了快乐层面、为了提升体验和让经历变得更好，而是更多地为了不想去感受某种特定的东西——不想感到压力、无聊、尴尬或不知所措——这就是与这种物质建立的一种不同的关系。
That is a negative-driven or a removal of negative-feeling-driven, like relationship where, again, we're experiencing negative reinforcement. We want to be experiencing positive reinforcement where we're like, oh, this is making things better for me rather than it's meaning that things aren't getting worse. At that point, weed is not just something you enjoy. It's something that you lean on. And it's something that you specifically rely on to regulate inner well-being, whether you
那是一种由负面驱动的、或者说由摆脱负面感受驱动的关系，在这种关系中，我们再次体验到的是负面强化。我们本来应该去体验正面强化，即那种觉得“哦，这让事情对我来说变得更好了”，而不是“这意味着事情没有变得更糟”。到了那个地步，大麻就不再只是你享受的东西了。它是你有所依仗的东西。而且它是你专门用来调节内心幸福感的东西，无论你
realize it or not. It is a relief-oriented pattern of use. Another distinct warning sign is when weed starts affecting how clearly you think and function on a daily or regular basis. If your memory feels worse, if your concentration is wavering, or it's getting harder to stay motivated and follow through on not just ordinary responsibilities, but things you really want to do, that is worth noticing A, acting on B. These effects can creep in gradually, of course, which is partly why people miss them. But over time, there will come a point where you will tip into this new mental state where you're like, I just
是否意识到这一点。这是一种以解压为导向的使用模式。另一个明显的警告信号是，当大麻开始影响你在日常或规律生活中的思考和运作清晰度时。如果你的记忆力变差了，如果你的注意力在动摇，或者保持动机并坚持做完事情变得越来越难——这不仅指日常责任，还包括你真正想做的事情——这就值得 A，付诸行动，B。这些影响当然会不知不觉地逐渐渗入，这也是人们忽视它们的部分原因。但随着时间的推移，总会有一个时刻，你会陷入这种新的精神状态，你会觉得：“我只是
I'm not the same person as I used to be. And I don't really like that. That is a clear sign that something needs to change and that you can change as well since you've noticed. And finally, a different kind of red flag, one that may not be as common is when your body starts showing signs of dependency. If you feel irritable, anxious, restless, unable to sleep, your appetite is messed around or revolves around weed, that suggests that your system has adapted to regular use. And you've developed a new kind of base line. And that is indicative of this kind of chemical dependency alongside of psychological dependency we've kind of been speaking about.
我不再是以前那个我了。我其实并不喜欢这样。”这是一个明确的信号，表明有些事情需要改变，而且既然你已经注意到了，你也是可以改变的。最后，还有一种不同类型的危险信号，这种信号可能没那么普遍，那就是当你的身体开始表现出依赖的迹象时。如果你感到易怒、焦虑、坐立不安、失眠、食欲被打乱或围绕着大麻打转，这表明你的系统已经适应了规律的使用。并且你已经形成了一条新的基准线。这标志着除了我们一直在谈论的心理依赖之外，还存在着这种化学依赖。
It's really important at this stage that you cut down because physical dependency, I know people talk about weed as a gateway drug, especially when you experience a physical dependency where you, like, you need to smoke so much, that is when you can start looking for other ways to get the same feeling. That is when you can start escalating usage to the point where it is really, really psychologically disruptive alongside physically disruptive. And look, again, I'm not trying to villainize it at all. I would be a hypocrite if I did, but we also can't pretend it's harmless either. I think this is why the conversation around weed is so difficult is because there's either people,
在这个阶段戒减真的非常重要，因为生理依赖——我知道人们把大麻当作一种入门毒品，特别是当你经历生理依赖时，比如你需要抽很多很多，这就是你开始寻找其他途径来获得同样感觉的时候。这就是你开始升级使用量，直到它除了在生理上具有破坏性之外，还在心理上带来极具破坏性的程度。听着，再说一次，我绝不是想把它妖魔化。如果我这么做了，我就是个伪君子，但我们也不能假装它是无害的。我想这就是为什么关于大麻的讨论如此困难，因为要么有人
people who want to say it only harms people or there's people who want to say there are absolutely no issues with it and people just need to chill out. No, it's somewhere in the middle, which is that individuals are going to react differently to this substance. People do go on to develop really severe mental health conditions in response to smoking weed. Psychosis from weed or from cannabis, schizophrenia from the consumption of cannabis is real. It's not just like something that is used to scare people. There are certain individuals who have a personality, genetic, temperament, vulnerability, psychological vulnerability that means their schizophrenic, psychotic symptoms remain
人们想说它只会害人，要么有人想说它完全没有任何问题，人们只需要放轻松。不，真相在中间，那就是每个人对这种物质的反应各不相同。确实有人在吸大麻后发展出非常严重的心理健康问题。由大麻引起的精神病，或者由消费大麻引起的精神分裂症是真实存在的。这不仅仅是用来吓唬人的东西。确实有某些人拥有某种人格、基因、气质脆弱性、心理脆弱性，这意味着他们的精神分裂症、精神病症状一直
on, like, remain untriggered until they smoke weed. and that can genuinely, that is life changing for them. And that is like, it's life changing. So be careful. Be safe. Know if your family has a history of that. Go slow and just like take care of yourself. Like if, again, I think it all comes down to this.
处于未被触发的状态，直到他们吸了大麻。这真的会彻底改变他们的人生。这就像是，它改变了人生。所以要小心。要安全。了解你们家族是否有这方面的病史。慢点来，照顾好自己。就像，再次强调，我认为这一切都归结于此。
If this experience is elevating life for you and making, if it's elevating already positive experiences, elevating time with your friends, elevating your creative practice, elevating your mood on a beautiful, sunny day, go for it. But if you are honest with yourself and it's not doing those things, or if you're just doing it to keep up with a partner, with a friendship group, or you're just doing it to avoid other stuff that's going on, that is not a healthy state of mind to be in at the very minimum when consuming weed. And it's not a healthy place to be in in terms of risk of dependency. So that's what I'm going to leave it at. I do think we can be quite a spiritual,
如果这种体验正在提升你的生活，让那些本就积极的体验更加美好，提升你和朋友在一起的时光，提升你的创作实践，提升你在阳光明媚的美好日子里的心情——那就去吧。但如果你对诚实面对自己，发现它并没有做到这些，或者你这么做只是为了跟上伴侣或朋友圈的步伐，又或者你只是为了逃避其他正在发生的事情，那么在消费大麻时，这绝对不是一种健康的心理状态。而且就依赖风险而言，这也不是一个健康的地方。这就是我要总结的观点。我确实认为大麻可以是一种相当精神上的、
positive thing, quite psychologically rewarding. But when it isn't that for you, it requires closer examination. And I hope that this episode has allowed you to do that or allowed you to do that in in regards to a relationship that you're in or in regards to a friendship or somebody that you know who might also be struggling with whether weed is a good or bad choice for them or their relationship to it. I'm going to leave a couple of links in the description for you guys to check out further if you like have concerns or worries, but also if you just want to do some deeper research, I know we couldn't touch on everything today. Again, this is meant to be a bonus episode. It's now like almost an hour long. So I'm sorry. But if you want a part two, let me know.
积极的事物，在心理上很有回报。但当它对你而言并非如此时，就需要进行更仔细的审视。我希望这一集能让你做到这一点，或者让你在面对自己身处的关系、友情，或者某个你认识的、可能也在挣扎于大麻对自己或其关系到底是好是坏的选择的人时，能够进行这样的审视。我会在简介里留几个链接，如果你有顾虑或担忧的话可以去看看，当然如果你只是想做些更深入的研究也可以。我知道我们今天不可能面面俱到。再次说明，这本来只是一期加更集。现在它快有一个小时长了。所以我很抱歉。但如果你想要第二部分，请告诉我。
If you've made it this far, leave leave a little comment down below. Let me know that you're still here. A reminder as well, you can always watch episodes of the podcast. on Netflix if you prefer video content. You can follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. That's where I got a lot of questions for today's episode from. And it's a great place to connect with me and other members of the podcast listener community. I don't know what else I need to tell you guys. Yeah, just hope you enjoyed the episode.
如果你听到了这里，在下方留个小评论吧。让我知道你还在。另外提醒一下，如果你喜欢视频内容，你随时可以在Netflix上观看播客节目。你可以在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。今天的很多问题都是从那里收集的。这也是与我和播客听众社区的其他成员交流的好地方。我不知道我还得告诉你们什么。好吧，只希望你们喜欢这一集。
And if there's something I didn't cover, feel free to mention it down below. But until next time, be safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. Definitely be safe. And we will talk very, very seriously. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
如果有什么我没有涵盖的内容，请随时在下方提及。但在此之前，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。一定要注意安全。我们将进行非常非常严肃的谈话。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。
It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley, feed on the IHeart Radio app.
吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波发生谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑期时显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我将把它带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《骨谷》中的恶魔采石场。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS.
Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你走向更快乐生活的新旅程——《快乐101》（Joy 101）。这是一档由我主持的新播客，我叫霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit, season two, is about both of those things.
每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，自从我出生以来，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托尔纳德斯（Javier Tornandez），在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。这里有一件本不该这么复杂的事情——移除种族主义雕像。还有一件本该容易得多却并非如此的事情——在原址立一座新雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》第二季讲的就是这两件事。
As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation.
当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大意味着什么？在这个城市里，对奴役者的致敬比对被奴役者的致敬还要多。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。每个家庭都有秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我的身份撒谎吗？我感到了如此深切的绝望。
I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to deep cover the family man. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得这是我不得不做的事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听深度报道《家庭主夫》（Deep Cover: The Family Man）。这是一档IHeart播客，品质保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。